>>Wayne Pan: How is it going, everyone?
>> Terrific.
>>Wayne Pan: Have a seat, please. We are about
to begin.
Hi.
So my name is Wayne Pan. I'm lead -- front-end
engineer on the Google ads team.
I am not here today to talk to you about how
to build a mobile application but how to build
a mobile business and the tools we have available
for you to actually do that.
I game to Google about a year ago through
the AdMob acquisition and a few years before
that we were building a successful ad network
on WAP, for those of you that remember WAP.
And then all of a sudden the iPhone happened
and I was part of the team that led the development
of our first i OS ads SDK. And just like everyone
else we were completely shocked and blown
away at the growth in the coming years.
And then we started expanding our platform
onto multiple emerging platforms, like Android,
Web OS, and now Windows phone 7.
Every month, at last count, more than 50,000
applications monetized with AdMob and Google
every month.
So as the mobile ecosystem, mobile app ecosystem
evolves and develops, developers need to evolve
and develop and so do the tools.
So today we are going to give you an overview
of how mobile advertising works in mobile
applications, and more advanced topics such
as cross-motion, mediation, and even analytics.
So hopefully by the end of this session you
guys will have a better idea how to build
a mobile business, whether or not you have
a company and a team that you are already
working with or you simply have an idea.
So before we get started, here is the QR code
to leave feedback for the session. If this
session is useful, how well I am doing as
a speaker, things like that. Please leave
feedback for all your sessions. That's how
we know we can improve I/O.
If you are twitting use io2011 and you guys
are on the Android track so use the hashtag
Android.
If you guys have questions you can login Google
moderator. There is the URL. I will put this
slide up at the end of the presentation also.
So how many of you out there have actually
built an app and put it in the app store or
marketplace? Raise your hands. Quite a few
of you guys. All right.
So how do you actually make money off of applications?
I am going to go through four basic mobile
business strategies.
So first of all, paid downloads. Pretty obvious.
You put the app in the app store or marketplace.
You charge the user a fee, let's say a $1.99,
and you take a cut after the app store or
marketplace or sometimes even the carrier
has taken a cut.
It's a one-time monetization fee. Games are
very successful with this strategy.
Keep in mind these aren't succinct business
models, but you can mix and match and use
a variety of them. I am just going to explain
to you what each one of them refer, to the
strategy behind them.
The next one is freemium. This is where you,
as a developer, put an application, sometimes
ad supported, sometimes with limited functionality,
you put it in the app store for free and you
build your audience and you get a bunch of
users and you try to up-sell them or convert
them into a paid download, either by offering
them incentives, such as more features, more
levels, or simply removing the ads if your
free app is ad supported.
Many businesses are successful with this.
One of them is Outfit 7. They produce an app
called Talking Tomcat. If you have kids, kids
love this app. My nieces and nephews love
it. It's a little cat that talks and it's
ad supported. You can download a paid version
and you will get more voices, more gestures,
things like that. They have a variety of talking
animal apps.
The next business strategy is in app purchases
or virtual goods. This is where you put in
a, most often, free application in the app
store, and you monetize your users with virtual
goods, either more levels, selling them more
gold for a price or a better sword. Our good
friends at Realview have used this strategy
successfully in Angry Birds. Even though it's
a paid app, they offered a virtual good called
the mighty eagle. For 99 cents, you can pay
them to get this massive bird called the mighty
eagle that will allow you to skip a level.
It's very successful. They found a way to
use virtual goods to monetize their game.
If you get a chance, definitely look it up.
It's a very good case study on how they were
successfully able to do that.
So the last one which we're going to focus
on today is advertising.
So first of all, what is advertising? We work
with thousands of publishers. Like I said,
we have over 50,000 publishers and apps -- or
50,000 apps monetizing with our platform.
Ads, what you do is, as a developer, you download
our SDK. AdMob and Google conveniently provide
one. There are many more ad networks out there,
though. You download the SDK as a developer.
You, as a developer, get to choose where the
ads show up in the app, how often they show
up. It's very simple integration.
So you integrate, you launch the app in the
app store or marketplace. The user downloads
your app. They open it, they play the game
or they use the application. They come across
an ad that's relevant to them or that they
want to check out. They tap on it, and you
make some money. It's simple as that.
Now, keep in mind that this is -- You have
the choice on how often and where you want
the ads to be shown. So that means every time
a user opens an application, you have a chance
to monetize them, versus some of the other
business models, it's more of a one-time thing.
But with advertising, users get a free app.
They like that because they don't have to
pay, and you as a developer get to monetize
every time a user is engaged with the application.
We have a session tomorrow, some of the AdMob
engineers are going to show you how to integrate
both, I think, the Android and iOS and Windows
7 SDKs. It's at 1:45 tomorrow. So if you have
time and you are interested, please attend
that session. I think it's in Room 9.
So let's talk a little bit more about advertising
and -- whoops.
Hold on one second here.
Sorry. I jumped ahead.
So let's talk a little bit more about the
terms behind advertising. So these are some
basic concepts on advertising. If you are
familiar with these, don't worry. This will
go by pretty quickly.
The first term we are going to talk about
is cost per click or CPC. This is how much
money you get paid when a user clicks on an
ad.
We are going to go through some examples so
we are going to use example numbers here and
in our examples we are going to use ten cents
as a cost per click. So you get paid ten cents
every time a user clicks on an ad -- or clicks
on an ad in your application.
The next term is ad request. This is when
your application goes out to the ad network
and says I want to show an ad. Simple as that.
So in the examples we are going to use 120,000
ad requests.
Now, this is different than impressions, which
is the next term. An impression is actually
when an ad is shown in your application and
the user has a chance to click on it. So not
every ad request results in an impression,
and I will explain that later and the terms
behind that.
And in our example, as I said, 100,000 impressions.
The ads were shown 100,000 times.
The fourth one on this slide is clicks. So
we're going to use 1500 clicks, and clicks
are self-explanatory. That's when the user
actually taps on an ad in your application.
So combining some of these terms is a more
advanced term called click-through rate. This
is a good measurement for when -- a measurement
of how relevant the ads are to the users.
So click-through rate is calculated by clicks
divided by impressions. So in our example,
like I said, 1500 clicks divided by 100,000
impressions results in a 1.5% CTR. So 1.5%
of the time a user saw an ad, they liked it
and clicked on it because it was helpful to
them, and so in our example, 1.5% CTR.
The next term is revenue, how much money you
are making.
That's calculated by the number of clicks
multiplied by the cost per click, pretty easy.
1500 clicks multiplied by ten cents results
in $150 in revenue.
So for these numbers, the publisher here made
$150.
Now, the next term is a little bit more advanced
term, eCPM. This is effective cost per million.
It's essentially, in simple terms, how much
money am I expected to make per thousand impressions.
This is a common metric to gauge ad networks.
It's not the only network, but it is one of
the most useful ones because there's multiple
ways you can buy advertising. In our examples
we are only use CPC. It's every time someone
clicks on an ad, you get paid. There's another
way to buy advertising, such as CPM. You can
get paid on an impression basis. CPA or cost
per acquisition. You get paid when there is
acquisition.
So eCPM is a way to measure across -- to level
the playing field and kind of have one metric
to judge how much money you are going to make
off of different ad networks.
So the calculation is revenue divided by a
thousand -- or divided by impressions multiplied
by a thousand. So that's expected cost per
-- or expected revenue per thousand impressions.
So in our example, 150 divided by 100,000
times a thousand, $1.50. So for every thousand
impressions, you expect to make $1.50. Pretty
straightforward.
I said earlier not every ad request results
in an impression, and that number is called
fill rate. It's essentially impressions divided
by ad requests. So in this example, 100,000
impressions from 120,000 ads, 83% fill rate.
Now, fill rate some people would expect to
be 100 percent but there are many reasons
why an ad request doesn't result in an impression.
There are things such as available ad inventory.
GO is a large one. There may not be a relevant
ad to serve to someone in Finland, for example.
It's just a fact of ad networks, and not reaching
100 percent fill is common and it's not something
that should be looked down upon because it's
-- it shows that we want -- as an ad network
and as a developer, too, you want to show
the most relevant ad to your user. And in
some cases there may not be one. Simple as
that.
Let's combine all these terms I have been
talking about into a more complicated scenario.
So in this scenario that's on the screen back
there, ad network A is offering you a dollar
eCPM. That's $1 for every thousand ad impressions.
They are offering you 83% fill rate. So your
expected revenue per thousand requests is
going to be a dollar multiplied by 83%, or
83 cents. So for every ad request, you are
going to make 83 cents.
Now, ad network B is offering you a $3 eCPM,
which is $2 more than network A, yet they
only fill 25% of their ad requests. So for
every hundred ad requests, you only get 25
ads.
So $3 eCPM multiplied by 25% fill rate, 75
cents. So you can see eCPM of network B is
much larger than network A but you will be
make being more money, your revenue will be
much higher -- or higher than with Network
A, going with ad network A.
So as a developer, you are probably thinking
to yourself, okay, so what if I want to use
both ad networks? Maybe why should I stick
with one? And you would be right.
So for those of you that have apps in the
marketplace or apps store and are using advertising
to monetize -- How many of you are using more
than one ad network? Only a few of you. Okay.
So I am going to show you why you would want
to use more than one ad network.
So this is a chart of eCPM over time, of just
some fictitious ad network A.
eCPM fluctuates for a variety of reasons,
just like fill fluctuates. Campaigns coming
online, different mix in inventory, seasonality.
Q4 is a big quarter for ads. So it's natural
to have CPMs fluctuate over any given amount
of time. It's natural.
But not every ad network's CPM fluctuates
-- or eCPM fluctuates in the same way. So
in this case, ad network A's eCPM is lower
at the beginning of whatever we have as time
there than network B's, but it goes above
network B in the middle and then C takes over,
so on and so on.
So as a developer, what would you do in this
scenario? Should you pick A? Should you pick
B? Should you pick C?
Well, you obviously want to make the most
money. That's what you guys all want to do;
right? We want you guys to make the most money.
So to accomplish that, you would want to be
on the top of all these charts. So you want
to pick the highest or optimal eCPM at any
given time, no matter what network. You want
to serve that ad network's ad at any given
time. So what you want to do is called mediate.
You want to mediate between multiple ad networks.
And mediation means in any ad slot, so in
this application here arcs the top of that
-- there's one ad slot at the top of this
app, and mediation allows you to serve any
ad network into that ad slot.
Let's say this week, ad network A is making
the most money. You can serve ad network A's
into that ad slot. Next week, it's ad network
B.
This is a little bit more complicated on mobile
than it is on desktop because users download
apps and you can't change things on the fly.
So mediation is important. So Google and AdMob
offer a free solution. This is 100 percent
open source. It's called ad whirl. It's at
AdWhirl.com. You can use it free of charge
and you can also look at the code to know
that we're not doing anything fishy.
You can even launch your own version of AdWhirl,
if you want. It's that open.
And AdWhirl allows you to use unlimited number
of ad networks, any number of them. You can
turn them on and off on the fly in real time.
You can change allocation percentages. You
can maximize your revenue by using mediation.
There's many other mediation solutions out
there. This one provides some pretty basic
functionality. And we understand that mediation
is important, so we're building mediation
as the core functionality of AdMob. We are
not ready to announce anything yet but we
are going to have an announcement in a few
weeks, so stay tuned for that.
Okay.
So you have built an app, and you have started
monetizing that. Now what's the next natural
step? It's to build another app; right?
So further of you who raised your hands earlier
who have built an app, how many have built
another, a second app? Quite a few. Okay.
All right.
So let's take a look at active users over
time. This chart represents the adoption of
app A over time. It's a pretty common curve.
Many apps are different. This is not applicable
to every app, but this is a pretty common
adoption curve. Little bit slow at first,
reaches a peak. Some users tail off, and you
have some sticky users at the end.
When you build a second app, or let's say
there's another app, it would follow generally
the same adoption curve. Now, app A and app
B could be from different publishers, but
if you guys have built two apps or multiple
apps, do you actually have control over app
A and app B. So how could you take advantage
of that to increase or -- increase the slope
of the user adoption of app B? How could you
somehow take advantage? You already have an
app. You already have an active user base,
to start getting users on app B or to start
building a brand, start building a business.
If you can do something like that, it would
be awesome; right?
You increase the slope. App B's adoption skyrockets
and you get users right away for your successive
apps.
So it turns out you can because you have app
A. And doing this is called cross-promoting,
or house ads, as our feature is called.
What you are doing is you are taking your
active users from app A and driving them to
also adopt your second application. And I
will show you how to do that in a bit. But
here is a little case study of one of the
most successful -- or one of our more successful
cross-promoters on Internet network. This
is Backflip Studios. You guys may know them
from Paper Toss.
So in this slide here, you can see that they
are using Strike Knight and Nin Jump. At the
bottom, you see an ad for Buganoids on both
those applications. So users or players of
Strike Knight and Nin Jump, they see the ad
Buganoids, they click on it, and they land
on the app store's landing page, and they
see it's also from Backflip. Hey, I like Strike
Knight, I like Nin Jump. Why shouldn't I try
out Buganoids?
We find that cross-promoting and house ads
cause a much higher conversion rate because
and if users like your application, they will
generally trust you and download successive
apps. And Backflip Studios has built a brand
around this, has built a business, an actual
business.
So I am going to show you a demo of how to
create a house ad using AdMob. So hopefully
this will work.
All right. So this is AdMob.com. It's a free
service, self-service. You can sign up, AdMob.com
if you haven't already. I am going to show
you a small section which is just our house
ads functionality to create a cross-promotion
ad.
So I am going to play the role of the publisher.
I have an app out there, it's called Golden
Gate Defender, it's a game. I have created
another app called Aliens Attack, and I want
to start cross-promoting it. I want to drive
users that are using Golden Gate Defenders
into Aliens Attack.
So I come to AdMob.com. I go to the house
ad section. I create an ad. It's an Android
marketplace ad -- or app, so I am going to
link to the marketplace. I am just going to
call it Aliens Attack promo. So the URL is
basically the URL of your marketplace app.
And I want to advertise that in my app, which
is Golden Gate defense.
And then from there, I can start to choose
where I want the ads to show up.
I've already picked I want it to show up in
Golden Gate Defense. But what countries I
do want it to show up in?
I'm actually just going to pick U.S., because
maybe I haven't internationalized the app
yet. You can see here, you can highly target
via Geo which -- where this app shows up.
So let's say you want to make a heavy push
into Germany, you can pick Germany and run
a promo for that.
And you can pick just any country that you
want.
After that, I can pick which devices I want
this to run on. So the first one is going
to be -- or my first option is to run on all
Android devices. I can pick specific Android
devices here. This is a list of all the Android
devices that are in our network or they're
using your application. So you can see it
gets very specific. Google Nexus One, et cetera,
et cetera, G2.
You can also pick which versions. So let's
say my new game, Aliens Attack, only works
on Android 2.0. So I can pick 2.0. Then, from
there, I just simply need to create the ad.
So we offer banner ads and text ads. I'm just
going to create a regular text ad. The lowest
barrier to entry.
I can upload a custom tile, which is this
one here, or I can just pick a standard one.
I'm just going to pick a standard one for
this demo here. That's this little thing on
the left.
This is what my ad is going to look like.
So I'm going to start typing. Download Aliens
Attack free now. And that's it.
My ad is done. I hit "create ad," and finish.
And there you go. And my ad's created. This
will run in my Golden Gate Defense, the users
will see this ad. If they like Golden Gate
Defense, hopefully, they'll download my Aliens
Attack game.
In here, there's a bunch of reporting after
the fact. It will immediately be scheduled,
start running. You can track clicks, your
conversion rate. You can track all kinds of
things. We have some enhancements coming up
to House ads that will be coming in a couple
weeks also. So stay tuned.
Hopefully this works again.
All right. All right. So now we've talked
about how to make money off of the applications,
all the business models that are available.
We've talked about how to cross-promote your
applications. We could, you know, jump-start
your successive applications.
So let's talk about what do you do now? There's
a lot going on. You've got a business, you've
got a couple apps, maybe your cross-promoting,
you're making money. What should you do? You
should start to measure and analyze your business;
right?
Next logical step.
How many of you who have shipped an app also
have an Analytics package in your app?
A few people. All right, you guys are on the
right track.
So we -- well, if you're Android developer,
there are -- this is -- screen looks probably
very familiar to you. Simply the number of
downloads that you have for your application
over time. And you can get a little bit -- slightly
deeper by looking at which countries your
apps have been downloaded in.
But what's lacking here is, you know, deeper
metrics, like user loyalty, engagement. How
many people have reached level 5 in your application?
What is the most-used feature in your application?
Where should you focus your energy on? Where
should you be devoting your development resources
on? Maybe nobody has reached level 10. Is
there a bug in my app? Maybe. I don't know.
So how do you do that?
Well, you can use Google Analytics. We provide
a mobile ads SDK -- or mobile Google Analytics
SDK that provides the same great functionality
as Google Analytics desktop. You can measure
engagement, loyalty, all those things I just
said.
In this example here, this is actual data
from an app. This is visitor loyalty. So this
is measuring over the last three days how
many repeated uses -- how many users have
repeatedly used my app.
So if you can't read it, it's a little bit
hard to read, but the bucket that has the
most is 15 to 25 times, followed very closely
by 25 to 50 times. And that tells me a lot.
That tells me that my users are engaging and
using my app at least once a day. A lot of
them. At least 34%. I can't do the math in
my head. But a lot of them are using my app
every single day. That's great. 'Cause if
I'm monetizing, like I said, with ads, every
time the user engages with my application,
I have a chance to monetize them.
So for a majority of my users, I'm monetizing
them every day.
Now, if you install Google Analytics and your
chart looks a little different, there's maybe
some improvements that you can do. But without
Google Analytics, you won't know this deep
dive into data. You won't know anything more
than just past downloads. And if you can't,
you know -- if you don't know these metrics,
like, you can't improve it. That's the basic
concept of good engineering, right? If you
can't measure it, you can't improve it.
So getting started with Google Analytics is
-- or Analytics for Mobile Applications is
very easy. Download the SDK, available in
iOS and Android. Code.Google/mobile/analytics.
And then go to Google Analytics or sign up
for an Analytics account as you would any
other site. And then create a profile for
your app. There's the -- the Google Analytics
team is doing a session tomorrow also at 12:30.
Please attend if you're interested in doing
some deeper integrations.
And going to go through deeper concepts than
we're going to cover here.
They launched last week something called e-commerce
tracking. This is applicable if you're selling
virtual goods, you can actually measure which
virtual good is doing well, which ones do
users like. Is it the blue sword or the green
sword, et cetera. If you're selling actual
goods, you can do the same e-commerce tracking
that you would do on a desktop site.
They also launched Android referral tracking.
If you're advertising your app, you can see
which sources are driving the most engaged
users. Where am I spending my money and getting
the most value. And it may turn out that House
ads you're getting the most value, so you
may be wanting to devote some of your inventory
-- forgoing some of your ad inventory for
House ads. These are things that you can find
out with Google Analytics.
So we covered building -- or building a mobile
business, all the ways you can monetize; cross-promotion,
cross-promoting your apps. Mediating, using
more than one ad network, which we are totally
cool with you doing. And Analytics.
So all these, we're launching a new site,
this is actually -- we're actually announcing
it in this session, called the App Galaxy
Map. It's at guidetotheappgalaxy.com.
It covers measuring, promoting, earning, everything
we covered in this session today, plus case
studies from successful businesses. It's a
really cool, well-put-together microsite.
And we hope you like it. We're launching it
and announcing it here.
So
with that, we're going to move on to Q&A.
So if you have questions, please come up to
the mike in the front. And I'll hopefully
answer them.
[ Applause ]
>>> I'm curious if there is ever a chance
that Google will allow us to have a special
permission specifically for Analytics so that
we're not required to incur the full Internet
permission if we just need to send Analytics
data.
>>Wayne Pan: I actually don't know the answer
to that. I'm not sure if they're having office
hours, but that would be something to ask
them. Or I can ask and you can find me offline.
But that's definitely a good thing to find
out.
So --
>>> When I -- when are you guys going to support
larger ad formats on AdWhirl?
>>Wayne Pan: On AdWhirl?
>>> Yeah.
>>Wayne Pan: Like I said when I mentioned
AdWhirl, we're actually developing mediation
into our core AdMob product. We're not ready
to announce anything yet. But if you find
me after, I can maybe show you a sneak preview.
>>> All right.
>>Wayne Pan: I'm going to take a question
from the moderator.
The first question is which ad position does
Google recommend which would generate the
most revenue in Android apps.
We've had a bunch of experience with this,
multiple publishers. We find the way -- where
you put your ad has a great effect on how
much money you're going to make.
Users generally don't want to be -- if you're
using -- if they're using your app, let's
say it's a game, they generally don't want
to be bothered by an ad. So they're not -- probably
not likely to click on it. Like, if I'm sitting
down and ready to play a game and the first
thing I see is an ad, no, I want to play your
game. That's why I opened your app in the
first place.
So we found -- let's talk about games specifically.
We found that if you put your ad in between
levels or at the end of a score screen, you
know, the user has consumed your app, they're
done with it, they'll most likely -- at that
point, they'll be ready to click on an ad.
They'll be ready to go somewhere else.
So you need to think -- as a developer, you
need to think what would I want as a user.
You don't want users to leave your application.
You want them to engage. You want to give
them a good experience. You want them to come
back.
So we find that putting an ad placement in
the -- in a spot in which users are ready
to move on to the next thing or they're finished
with your experience is the best place and
it's going to definitely make you the most
money.
>>> So I was wondering, are there tools to
get competitive data, competitive application
data, how they're doing versus how my app
is doing statistically?
>>Wayne Pan: Application on how many downloads
or were you talking about --
>>> So if I have a gaming application of a
certain kind, then how are the other gaming
applications doing?
>>Wayne Pan: In what metric?
>>> Competitive, as in someone else is giving
information how they are performing in Android
Market versus mine.
>>Wayne Pan: So you can rank in the Appstore
is good one obviously. There's no tools that
we have that you can build. But, I mean, we
found the developer community is pretty -- they're
willing to share. There's probably a bunch
of developers. The person next to you has
probably developed a game application, so
you can probably ask them. Yeah. I'm sorry.
>>> Thank you.
>>> Hi. Is Google Analytics open source? And
how is it compared to Flurry?
>>Wayne Pan: I think the server side is open
sourced. I'm not sure if the SDK is. I believe
so. But it's -- Flurry's a great product.
And actually one of our good friends. But
Google Analytics is -- we're adapting the
-- all the features they have in Google Analytics,
which is, I believe, one of the leading free
Analytics solutions, onto mobile. So all the
great features that you know and love from
desktop version of Google Analytics or Web
site versions, you'll be able to take advantage
and do deep tracking, deep thinking, all the
great stuff that you'll do in desktop, we're
going to make them available -- or they are
available in Google Analytics Mobile. So I
can't say feature for feature which one is
better, but -- I don't know if that answers
your question.
But definitely --
>>> Is there anything that Google Analytics
-- Analytics can do that Flurry can't?
>>Wayne Pan: I don't know. You're going to
have to ask the Google Analytics team. Or
I can hook you up with one of them if you
find me after.
>>> Okay. Thanks.
>>Wayne Pan: Okay. Well, we're going to take
one more question from Google Moderator here.
So this question is what is the best way to
make money with an app, free, ad supported,
or paid app?
So it really depends. We like advertising,
obviously. Advertising-supported apps. Users
love them because they don't have to pay to
experience your app. And like I said, a paid
app download is a one-time monetization event.
The user pays you when they download the app.
They get to use it indefinitely.
With ads, you can monetize every time the
user engages in your app. So it really depends.
I mean, some apps are better as a sale. Some
apps are better with ads. Some apps are better
with virtual goods. It just all depends on
what your app is and who your target audience
is.
So....
>>> Hi. I would like to know, on AdMob, if
there are any other ways for getting more
relevant ads other than filtering the categories.
>>Wayne Pan: So we have -- so filtering the
categories is -- we're working on key word
relevance for AdMob. But right now, you have
-- your options are -- a lot of our targeting,
our ads targeting, is going to be through
the device -- like I -- when I showed you
the House ads creation, is through device
or Geo.
We're working on piping through the key words
into AdSense. So you actually get AdSense
ads through AdMob. So if -- there's a key
word section in the SDK. And you can come
to office hours and we will show you how to
implement it if you don't know or you haven't
figured that out yet. But that's going to
be the best way to drive relevant ads into
your application.
Any other questions? No?
Okay. That's it. Thanks, everybody, for coming.
[ Applause ]